I have found it I have found the single
most perfect depiction of liberalism
ever
someday this photo will hang in a museum
the title will be liberalism year 2022
colorized the photo
is going around the internet right now
it's of a California man charging his
electric car with a portable gas powered
electricity generator it's a depiction
of a real thing in a real time and place
California actually cannot sustain its
power grid right now because of the
state's stupid left-wing energy policies
the only way that it has any hope of
making it through is by begging
residents to stop using power but
this is also a depiction of a broader
concept the libs upending tradition
overturning Society rejecting reality
only to watch as their crazy schemes all
of which relied on tradition and reality
collapse under their own weight
their own instability and then to be
forced to return to the tried and true
old ways except that they have to return
to them in the least efficient ways
possible you especially see this with
you know religion and kind of
traditional morality that's what all of
liberalism rests on then they try to get
rid of that and then the edifice falls
apart and then they have to try to
reconstruct religion and morality it
doesn't really work you look at the
engine gas and diesel-powered car
engines have very sophisticated emission
control technology
portable electric generators generally
speaking do not they're filthy the whole
thing is in fact much worse for the
environment than any of the normal cars
that normal people drive
pretty soon there's an idea pretty soon
maybe the libs will figure out that the
whole thing will move more smoothly and
efficiently if they just take that
portable generator that they've got and
and put it inside the car
and maybe they could put it underneath
the hood of the car
and then they could they can actually
take it with them on their drives and
they don't need to stop for an hour to
recharge the car at the special Port
they can actually just kind of pull over
at a at like a station
at a station that has gas at it and then
they refill the generators with gasoline
and then that will will charge their car
for the rest of the ride that is my
advice really high tech advice to all of
our listeners in California I will not
be following that advice myself because
I fled that liberal Wasteland and now I
live in Tennessee which despite having
much hotter Summers is believe it or not
able to keep the power grid running just
fine what a difference good government
insane politics can make I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Frank s who
says if anyone that votes against your
party is extremist then you don't have a
two-party system yes that's true in our
democracy right we have two parties but
if you if you vote for the other party
you're evil and a threat to democracy I
don't I don't think you have a democracy
anymore then I think when you have one
party Rule and isn't that totality or
something like that let's check in on
the state of liberalism we've got
portable electricity generators powering
the electric cars with fossil fuels in
California what do we think in the White
House what is the state of liberalism
right now from its most prominent
spokesman
you know how much
you know how much I'm gonna do with the
deficit this year one trillion 500 000.
one trillion five hundred thousand
okay that's this that is the state of
things and I think that is probably the
most coherent argument that you could
possibly give in defense of the Biden
administration's policies and of
liberalism generally that's it thank you
Mr President for selling more copies of
my national best-selling book uh reasons
to vote for Democrats a comprehensive
guide 260 blank pages there's really not
much of an argument here the the the
leader of the Free World allegedly uh
cannot speak
cannot make an argument for these
policies other people are doing the
talking for him here is one of the
people
who is leading a major Initiative for
the Biden White House this would be Joe
Biden's new monkey pox czar
this virus transmits through very close
skin to skin physical contact often in
the setting of sexual exposure but there
are other mechanisms for its
transmission including if you touch
objects that individuals who've had
monkey pox touch or if if you have
prolonged exposure to respiratory
droplets with that said signaling to
people who are in the gay bisexual other
men who have sex with men communities
and also transgender people who have sex
with men that it's really important to
have awareness that's at circulating in
the community is really a critical part
of the messaging while not generating
um you know inordinate concern and
really focusing on the infection as
linked to an identity so it's just an
infection it's not linked to an identity
it just happens to be in The Social
Network
I think it was easier to understand the
Rada because I don't have any idea what
that guy just said he said well you know
you understand that the the spread of
the virus of the monkey pox is primarily
among the gay and the bisexual and the
other men have I'm not he actually said
that the other men having sex with men
community and also the transgender
Community but there shouldn't be a
stigma associated with that because it's
not a virus that has an identity but it
is a virus that spreads among a certain
identity
that man's name is Dimitri dascalakis he
is the new White House monkey pox
coordinator
and uh now that he has been elevated to
this role there is a photo clearly from
a professional photo shoot that this man
signed up for this wasn't some gotcha
Paparazzi camera this is something that
this man went out dressed up for and got
these photos taken and it's of him
wearing a kind of slick looking suit
with his shirt unbuttoned all the way
wearing a leather harness on his chest
that has a pentagram the the symbol of
Satan right in the center of it
so we've got a
we've got a satanic leather fetishist
who is now running the White House
monkey pox policy we've got over at the
energy Department we have a leather
doggy fetishists who's vaguely
transgender I think his name is Sam
Brinton and then over at the health
department at the assistant Secretary of
health is a man who thinks that he is a
woman named Richard Levine who he thinks
he's a woman named Rachel Levine and he
believes that we need to put all of the
little kids uh who are sexually confused
onto cross cross-ex hormones
this this all coming to light after
Joe Biden gives his red speech where he
talks about the Battle for the soul of
the nation at night in the dark in front
of this very ominous looking red light
where he calls half the country evil
I'm starting to think Joe Biden might be
right I think we might be in a battle
for the soul of the nation
now Joe Biden hasn't specified which
side he's on in that battle for the soul
of a Nation but you know they say that
Personnel is policy and if that is the
case then the the policy doesn't see of
the Biden Administration doesn't seem to
be on the good side of that battle okay
when your prominent senior advisors are
openly wearing symbols of Satan and
leading leading human beings around by
dog collars
and sort of engaging in weird sadistic
sexual exploits and then trying to trans
the kids and mutilate their bodies and
pump them full of chemicals I think you
might be the Baddie you might be the
baddies on the bad side of this
this is a fight for the soul of the
nation and it's not just in the crazy
liberal cities and it's not just in
Washington DC Tennessee Tech Tennessee
Tech was just caught hosting a
a show this was at their back door
Playhouse
I assume pun very much intended this is
found by Landon Starbuck it was a drag
show
specifically for you know for all ages
mocking Christianity take a listen
[Music]
I walked out dressed up like a Christian
Monk
[Music]
just dropping dollar bills get it game
and not amen but gay men
then these things take me to church he
mocks the crucifix he makes the sign of
the cross while he's stripping doing
this kind of drag strip show
[Music]
wiggling jiggling taking off the habit
and he's also wearing some kind of weird
leather thing I don't know what it is
with the leather thing
and then taking money from all of the
other
very confused people who are in the
audience
this is all a reminder
that when you really get down to the
bottom of what politics is about it is
all about God I I use the quote on this
show very often from Cardinal Manning
that all politics all human conflict is
ultimately theological and we sometimes
forget that
we hear people say actually politics is
about the battle between Liberty and
equality uh actually no uh politics is
fundamentally the battle between
individualism and collectivism no
actually politics is the battle between
you know what it is it's a little more
basic than all of that politics is a
fight between good
and bad
and we've known this going back to
ancient Greece and we've known this
going back to all those good old Uncle
Aristotle and Socrates and Plato all the
way up through Antiquity through the
Middle Ages
in the modern era because we want to
deny the existence of God and the fact
that our lives are sustained their
existence itself is sustained by God we
want to deny that make everything sound
really secular and clinical so we say no
it's actually about this ideological
concept versus this one no it's not it's
just about good and bad and that's why
it keeps that's why it keeps coming down
to even our enlightened modern atheistic
agents why it keeps coming down to
mocking Christianity it's why it keeps
coming down because why it's why a
senior leader in the Biden
Administration is wearing avert satanic
symbols okay it's it's not just because
of some super high level double triple
irony from the atheistic materialistic
no it's it's something a little more
basic it's because
all of this human conflict is coming
down to basic questions of good versus
evil it's a battle for the soul of the
nation which side are you on
we want to fix the country we're going
to need to we're going to need to get
our hands dirty okay we need to do some
things for ourselves when you want to
for instance fix your car you got to
check out RockAuto right now head on
over to rockauto.com no one likes to
spend money on their cars you buy it you
drive it you want it to run forever
maintenance free is that what happens no
unfortunately that's not the way things
work cars require upkeep now the good
news is you can maintain your car for
less for a lot less when you shop for
Auto Parts at rockauto.com chain stores
have different price tiers for the pros
the mechanics and the do-it-yourselfers
rockauto.com's prices are the same for
everybody and they are reliably low
they're not going to change prices based
on what the market will bear like the
Airlines and the marketplace sites do
rockauto.com has been in the auto parts
business for 20 years it's family owned
their goal is to make Auto Parts
available and affordable to keep you
safe on the road they not only have the
auto parts you need but they will give
you a selection of trust name brands to
choose from you can get suspension
exhaust air conditioning other kits that
provide all the parts you need for a
successful repair head on over right now
to
rockauto.com you can use that super easy
to navigate catalog and then type in
Knolls in there how did you hear about
this box so they know that we sent you
speaking of clear lines
Whoopi Goldberg
is defending Karine Jean-Pierre the
White House Press Secretary
after Korean Champion got caught in
flagrant hypocrisy because she said that
anyone who denies elections any of the
Republicans who have raised any
questions about the 2020 election they
are fascists that's the definition of
fascism and then Peter Ducey the White
House reporter points that he says wait
a second Korean jump here you've said
that 2016 and the 2018 elections were
stolen so are you by that definition are
you a fascist and she said no no it's
different it's different when I do it
because I'm a Democrat well Whoopi
Goldberg is defending that line of
argument
let's also remember that she was part of
moveon.org she was not an elected
official she was she was doing her part
as an American citizen saying how she
felt about an election whether you like
it or not everybody talks about
everybody has the right freedom of
speech so that's the difference let's
discuss you know kind of some of the
folks that uh you know
are in office now who have denied that
that uh
my goodness that Biden is President I
mean it's just you know I I get so
frustrated because I think this is not
apples and oranges this is apples and
basketballs yeah
she almost gives up at the end did you
know when she when even Whoopi Goldberg
realizes gosh the argument I'm making
just doesn't make any sense at all gosh
maybe she pauses she almost gives up and
then she just kind of uses this
throwaway Zinger line and tries to move
on it says in apples and oranges it's
apples and basketballs how
Joe Biden said that any American who
questions the 2020 election is a fascist
then it turned out Kareem Jean-Pierre
questioned the 20 the 2016-2018
elections then Whoopi Goldberg said no
no she was a private citizen yeah I know
Joe Biden and Karine Jean-Pierre said
that private citizens not it wasn't just
Donald Trump it's Trump's supporters who
are private citizens who questioned the
2020 election are fascists so by that
standard
green Jean-Pierre and Joe Biden are
fascists
that's a stupid definition but by their
own definition they are fascists she
said no no but it's it's it's different
because she they have freedom of speech
right don't the Trump supporters also
have freedom of speech and also we're
not talking about whether they have the
freedom of speech we're talking about
the substance of their speech
and the Biden standard is that they're
fascists
but now you're denying and you say no
it's different it's and she when she
gets to that point at the end she's at
least being honest she's being
incoherent but she's being honest she's
saying look it's it's not apples and
oranges it's apples and basketballs
when Republicans and Democrats do the
exact same thing
actually if anything the Democrats did
so more egregiously and more uh
consistently
it's apples and basketballs
because the Republicans and the
Democrats are different because the
Republicans and the Democrats get
treated differently because there are
two tiers of Justice in America because
there are just one one group gets to do
whatever it wants
the other group can't do the very same
thing
that's what she's saying she's admitting
the double standard and she's doubling
down on the double standard
and she's saying it's a good thing how
are Republicans responding to these kind
of blatant Shameless attacks
here's how the RNC yesterday released an
ad they've got Joe Biden now you've got
the worst economy in recent history
You've Got 40-year High inflation you've
got the first major war in Europe you've
got record high numbers of foreign
Nationals pouring across the border
you've got crimes spiking throughout the
cities you got the average American life
expectancy decreasing yet the country is
in absolute shambles and here's how they
nailed Joe Biden they say that he's he
wasn't as much of a civil rights leader
as he said he was
when I marched in the Civil Rights
Movement
I did not march with a 12-point program
I marched with tens of thousands of
others to change attitudes
and we changed attitudes he lied to
voters according to the New York Times
quoting AIDS of bidens about having
marched in the Civil Rights Movement I
got involved in the Civil Rights
Movement if we got involved in this
segregated movie theaters they organized
voter registration drives from the time
I got involved as a high school kid in
the Civil Rights Movement but I was a
kid involved in the Civil Rights
Movement desegregating restaurants and
movie theaters in my state from the time
I got involved as a kid in the Civil
Rights Movement quote more than once
advisors had gently reminded Mr Biden of
the problem with this formulation he had
not actually marched during the Civil
Rights Movement and more than once Mr
Biden assured them that he understood
and kept telling the story anyway that
is really really weird
I have one question
who is this ad going to convince who is
this ad supposed to persuade what is
this ad supposed to do
the point of the ad is Joe Biden is a
liar which we've now first of all most
politicians are liars and we've we've
we've known that about Joe Biden since
he had to drop out of the 1988
presidential contest for lying
okay Joe Biden's a liar
so what
is this this is supposed to appeal to
the Democrats who
who
support Biden only because they thought
he was more of a civil rights leader
than he is that this is supposed to
convince the Republicans who who
what's the point of that I get the point
of the ad
is the point of the ad is the same
stupid line that Republicans Trot out
and they think it's going to work and
they think it's clever and it never
works the Democrats you see are the real
racists
you see the Democrats they call us
racists but they're the real racists and
they pretend to have a really good
record on Race but they actually don't
have a really good record on Race see
did we win any votes from that because
we never have before ever
but there are the real racists the
Democrats who use this term races and
they've redefined this term they've
they've made this the worst thing that
you could possibly be called in America
as a racist and they just use it
indiscriminately against Republicans
with absolutely no basis in any of the
Republicans actions they just use it
and it frames the whole argument and now
the best that the Republicans muster is
no you are
that's not going to work that's not
going to work
yes the Democrats are the real racists
they know that there was a
Senate candidate a democrat in I think
South Carolina yeah
uh Christy Matthews she just caught got
caught on camera with project Veritas uh
explaining to what she thought was a
sort of
private person in a private conversation
that everyone needs to treat white
people like s-h-i-t
I understand
[Music]
[Music]
and treat those white people like
s-h-i-t
what's the takeaway here here's what the
takeaway is not this is the one thing
that the takeaway is not the takeaway is
not goalie could you imagine if it were
a white person saying this about a black
person golly could you imagine if the
roles were reversed
gosh what would the media be saying then
it's so hypocritical
uh-huh they know that they know wow they
know they don't care that's the point
that's the point that my takeaway is not
could you imagine if no my takeaway here
is not that we need to point out the
hypocrisy constantly that's going to
fall on deaf ears it's not going to
persuade anybody the takeaway is
we need to change the game entirely
the game of who is the bigger racist is
a losing game because the whole thing
was established through a Democrat lens
there's no way to win it they have just
defined racism as anything Republicans
do and not anything the Democrats do
okay
the key here for republicans and
independents and normal people is just
don't take the bait
when they call you a racist just say
okay all right whatever whatever when a
liberal calls you a racist you know
you've won the argument it was a line
when I was a student I got to meet Ann
Coulter she came to my college and she
that line really stuck with me she
mentioned that she said when a liberal
because we were all complaining we said
the Liberals on campus they're calling
us racists but we're not racists we're
good people she said don't come on don't
worry about that when a liberal calls
you a racist you know you've won the
argument just move on don't give it any
air say okay what are they they're there
they go again that's the Ronald Reagan
line about Jimmy Carter okay there they
go again everything's racist okay move
on let's talk about the economy let's
talk about illegal immigration let's
talk about them transiting the kids
let's talk about the satanic leather
daddy in the white house right now let's
talk about the fight for the soul of our
nation you can go Babble about about
racism or
whatever Joe Biden said that's fine none
of that means anything we're going to
talk about stuff that matters
and we're going to look good when we do
it especially if we're wearing mizzen in
Maine right now go to mizzen and
maine.com use promo code at Knowles
you've got to check these guys out
missing in Maine it's the inventors of
the performance fabric dress shirt nizin
and Maine combines the comfort and
flexibility of your favorite athletic
wear with the fit and style of a custom
dress shirt I love it I love I wear
Oxford shirts all the time I've pretty
much never go outside without a collar
on and yet being of Sicilian descent you
know we perspire a little bit well
mizzen and Main figured it out they've
got the best of all worlds lightweight
breathable moisture wicking these will
have you looking great and their their
dress shirts are machine washable so you
can skip those trips to the dry cleaner
think of all the time and the money you
will save these guys were the first to
use performance Fabrics in men's
Workwear 10 years later they are still
the best by the way it's not just dress
shirts they've got wonderful comfortable
flannels they've got great polo shirts
they're just absolutely fabulous in
Maine just turned 10 so they've got
great deals running on their site All
Summer Long right now if you go to
Mission and main.com use promo code
Knolls you will receive 35 off any
regular price order of 125 bucks or more
that is 35 off when you go to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n.com use promo
code Knowles
speaking of racial identity politics big
headline here in the Washington Post a
big cause of Celebration among the libs
there's a new conservative prime
minister in the UK
and when I say conservative that the
Tories the UK conservatives are they're
really more like American Democrats and
then the left in the UK is much further
left even than we're seeing in the
mainstream in America right now
so the conservative party
has just elected this lady Liz truss and
here's the headline Liz truss's cabinet
is the UK's first without a white man in
any of the top offices
and my reaction to that all the libs are
saying this is great this is wonderful
this is such a big win for justice and
equality and diversity and and my
reaction was
that's kind of weird isn't it
it's because England
is a country
of the English
and the English are definitely very
white they are they are some of the
whitest people on earth
and so isn't it kind of we and Men you
know you generally speaking usually are
involved in politics uh historically
speaking men are most of the people
involved in politics so it's just kind
of weird that in England a country of
extremely white people
you wouldn't have even a single white
guy in any of the big government
positions and that kind of
I'm not saying it's necessarily the
worst thing in the world I'm just saying
isn't that it's weird it's not the sort
of thing that I certainly not something
I would celebrate
the the only reason you would celebrate
this is if you think white men are bad
which is
what the culture says right now the
culture is that when it comes right down
to it beyond all the really super clever
arguments that we all try to make and
beyond all the demos are the real
racists and all that stuff
there is a sense in the culture that
that white people broadly white men in
particular but white people broadly are
just bad
and white people are the only group that
you are it is socially acceptable to
insult or discriminate against that you
can legally discriminate against Asians
sometimes bear the brunt of it too in in
University admissions but white people
you can discriminate against them
through affirmative action and just in
the culture it's the only racial group
that you're allowed to Mock and actually
encouraged to mock
I think that seems kind of wrong doesn't
it and there's there's nothing that the
white people can do about it because it
it has nothing to do with the actions
that the white people take the culture
has just said white people are bad a
great example of this
is when white people move neighborhoods
when white people move into a black
neighborhood that is bad because that's
gentrification
but when white people move out of a
black neighborhood that is also bad
because that's white flight
so there is nothing the white people can
do that would not be bad and that's
because the goodness or Badness of it
has nothing to do with the actions it
has nothing to do with which
neighborhoods you move to or from it
just has to do with the white people
doing it because the white people are
doing it according to the culture it has
to be bad because the white people are
bad you see this when if white people
adopt some aspect of another culture
let's say they they I don't know they
eat tacos or something they wear certain
aspects of clothing
that is bad because that's cultural
appropriation they're not allowed to do
that
but but if white people don't adopt
aspects of other people's cultures that
is also bad that's called cultural
Erasure that's called
eurocentric you know cultural chauvinism
or something and they that's bad too why
is it bad because it has nothing to do
with the tacos and it has nothing to do
with the clothing it has everything to
do with white people doing it whatever
the white people do is defined as bad
this is what you're seeing reflected
right now in the Democrats and the
Republicans on the issues of so-called
election denial or political violence
when the Democrats deny many elections
going back at least 22 years now to the
2000 presidential election and
increasing in recent years 2016 Hillary
hasn't really conceded that race she
still says that it was a stolen election
Stacy Abrams hasn't hasn't really
conceded at all the 2018 Georgia Cuban
Trail race she still says it was a
stolen election
well it doesn't matter
that's fine that's good when when the
left burns the country down for eight
months with BLM and antifa that's fine
that political violence is fine it's not
even violence it's mostly peaceful
but when any Republican
suggests that hey maybe it's a little
weird that they changed all the election
rules
radically unlike anything we've ever
seen right before the 2020 presidential
election maybe that's a little weird
maybe that raises questions when some
grammas from the from the Midwest show
up to the capital rotunda and in many
cases are let in by police on January
6th that's considered the worst violent
Insurrection in American history that
was almost a coup d'etat
why it has nothing to do with
questioning elections it has nothing to
do with even political violence it has
everything to do with who does it
when the Democrats do anything it's good
when the Republicans do anything it's
bad Democrats could I was trying to
think of an example you know that would
be really egregious that were
hypothetical but I'll use a real one
Democrats could
could wear satanic symbols in in leather
harnesses in their professional
headshots that would be considered good
a republican could help a little old
lady cross the street that would be
considered an act of evil because of who
they are
so what's the takeaway from that
you've got to tune out the noise you
know there are a number of Republicans
who are very eager to hand it to the
Liberals to Grant certain premises well
you know actually the Democrats have a
point when they say that the horn hat
guy got a little out of control actually
you know Trump shouldn't have used this
certain kind of rhetor no they don't
they don't have a point
you don't have to hand it to them
actually the whole argument is
disingenuous
no no one on the Democrat side cares
about racism none of them care about
political violence none of them care
about questioning elections
they just want to beat you they just
don't want you to do anything that will
give you an advantage you do not have to
take any of that stuff seriously you
want it you want to see a great example
of this also from The Washington Post
pravta on the Potomac Washington Post
now has an exclusive article
on on what kind of material was seized
at Donald Trump's home
because going back 50 years now the
Washington Post always gets the leaks
out of the intelligence community
and so the Washington Post
is reporting they said you you mag are
Republicans you all said that Trump
didn't have any dangerous material at
Mar-A-Lago that it could you know there
was dangerous for him to have it was not
secure or could have gotten into the
wrong hands well we now know
that material on foreign Nations nuclear
capabilities
was seized at Mar-A-Lago
some seized documents were so closely
held only the president a cabinet level
or near cabinet level official could
authorize others to know
and by the way it's kind of funny that
they have that as the sub headline there
because
it undercuts their whole argument
because Donald Trump was the president
he did have ultimate declassification
Authority and so it's it is just simply
an absurdity to claim that a president
or former president for that matter
mishandled classified information it is
not
possible for a president or ex-president
to mishandle classified information the
very fact that he has been the president
precludes that but furthermore the whole
article is a cell phone
because the the insinuation here is that
it was really irresponsible maybe
illegal but certainly irresponsible for
Trump to have this material at
Mar-A-Lago because he had it there by
golly it was so unsecure it could have
leaked to the Press
oh
oh wait hold on so it
when the material was in Trump's home
with the padlock on the door no one
heard about it
but but then the minute that the FBI
took it that's when it all leaked sounds
like we should send all the classified
information to Mar-A-Lago sounds like
it's way safer there than it is in the
hands of the FBI but furthermore we're
being told now that this this material
at Mar-A-Lago it was so so hyper super
duper sensitive no one should be able to
even know that it exists and that's why
we're going to publish a whole article
in the Washington post about it now In
fairness very few people read The
Washington Post anymore I only read it
to make fun of it sometimes so it's true
I guess it's probably safe being printed
in the Washington Post because no one
subscribes
but doesn't that undercut you if this is
so super duper sensitive and Trump is
such a terrible person for for
endangering it you know and and risking
its release uh shouldn't we not be
publishing it in newspapers
seems it just all seems so disingenuous
to me speaking of which
speaking of regime propaganda media we
have in GQ
just a delightfully absurd profile of
AOC
who they're trying to set up to be a
future presidential candidate
here here are just some highlights from
it
she says people ask me questions about
the future and realistically I can't
even tell you if I'm going to be alive
in September and that weighs very
heavily on me and it's not just the
right wing misogyny transcends political
ideology Left Right Center this grip of
patriarchy affects all of us not just
women men as I mentioned before but also
ideologically there's an extraordinary
lack of self-awareness
in so many places
and that that might be the truest thing
she's ever said there is an
extraordinary lack of self-awareness
I'm pleased to report what day is it
it's September 8th
we are now more than a week into
September
AOC has survived she is alive good I'm
glad I'm glad you could make it AOC
what did she even mean by that I don't
even know if I'll be alive it's like
when she said I was afraid I was going
to be raped and murdered on January 6th
meanwhile she wasn't even in the same
building she was down the street from
from where the the very scary Midwestern
grandmothers were where the Florida dad
is sipping a Coors Light in the Rotunda
gosh golly could you imagine
there is an extraordinary lack of
self-awareness there is an extraordinary
lack of self-awareness but it doesn't
seem to harm her actually later on in
the profile
GQ asks her outright do you think that
you can be president and and the fear
that AOC has the the little
hesitation that she has to be president
is the scariest thing of all
now while radical gender ideologues to
cry the harms of Single Sex bathrooms
and comedy specials and dead named
celebrities also known as just named
celebrities kids are the ones suffering
recently the FDA issued a warning that
prescribed puberty blockers the ones
that transgender activists claim are
harmless and reversible can actually
cause vision loss and brain swelling and
all the things that we all knew
intuitively the experimentation on
children has got to end to fight back we
need to expose and defend the truth just
as my pal Matt Walsh has done in his
breakout documentary what is a woman
with over 5 000 audience ratings on
Rotten Tomatoes what is a woman is
pushing back against the left's
dangerous narratives help us keep the
momentum up by watching and sharing the
film at whatisawoman.com that is what is
a woman.com head on over there today
in this AOC profile in GQ she was asked
are you are you going to run for
president do you think you could be
president she says yeah maybe but here's
her hold up
she says could Obama have gotten elected
without the kind of financial support
that he had
right she she opposes Wall Street maybe
that'll hold her up then she goes
further she goes I don't know
they say even if she theoretically were
to become president then what she'd face
a system from the Senate to the Supreme
Court
both empowered and inclined to thwart
her most sweeping ambitions
there were still plenty of limitations
she said playing out that hypothetical
it's tough it's really tough so what's
tough
she's saying there are all these
limitations all these impediments
but she's not just talking about
corruption she's not just talking about
popularity she's not just talking about
the big Banks and the entrenched
interests
the the big impediment to her sweeping
presidential plans
that that they are describing is
our system of government
they're saying that the separation of
powers and system of checks and balances
is the big impediment it's tough It's
really tough I've got to deal with a
court
I have to listen to the legislature
I'll have to follow the Constitution
and that might impede me from doing what
I want to do what do they want to do
they want to upend the country
the country to them is bad
that's their starting point it's not
that they research the history of
slavery and they discovered America's
bad
but by that model every country in the
world is bad by the measure of slavery
America is the least Bad Country ever
it's not that they looked at the
interactions between the European
settlers and the Native Americans and
determined therefore that America's bad
it's not that they no they started with
the premise that America is bad
okay and then they formulate our
arguments usually species arguments to
back up that argument but it's it begins
with an antipathy for the country which
they want to upend they want to upend it
fundamentally that's when Barack Obama
said we're about to fundamentally
transform America he is expressing a
hatred for the country because you don't
want to fundamentally transform things
that you love when when AOC says that
the reason I might not run for president
is I'd have to deal with that awful
Constitution and I'm not sure I'd be
capable of upending the whole system of
government that expresses a hatred for
the country and the form of politics
that we have here
her problem is America and she needs to
overcome America to follow her to to
achieve her political ambitions
speaking of the Judiciary putting good
constraints on demagogues there's a
great ruling just came out of a U.S
District Court U.S District Judge Reed
O'Connor in Texas has just ruled that a
new rule
requiring employers to provide coverage
for drugs that are called prep drugs
violates the religious rights of
employers under federal law under the
the rifra rule
the religious freedom restoration act
this was totally the correct decision
why was it a correct decision though
these prep drugs are drugs that are
taken pretty much exclusively by
promiscuous homosexual men to prevent
them from Contracting AIDS the point of
the prep drugs they're apparently very
effective drugs is if you take them
before you engage in Risky activities
you are at a greatly greatly reduced
chance of Contracting AIDS like 99
reduced chance of Contracting AIDS so
then the question is who who is at risk
of Contracting AIDS
and the answer to that is overwhelmingly
I'm going to use the the most
conservative numbers possible here
two-thirds to three quarters of the
people who get AIDS are gay men that's
that's where the spread is
and then you've also got intravenous
drug users and then you've got and
you've also got people who
who unwittingly have sex with gay men
and you've got and and it's not just gay
men it's not men that just identify as
gay it's well it's gay men but it's men
who might say no I'm not a gay man I'm
as that monkey pox coordinator was
saying earlier I'm just a member of the
men who have sex with other men
community
which is somehow different than the gay
community or the bisexual Community or
the whatever but it's all it's all kind
of the same stuff that's that's how you
get AIDS
okay and so the question is
the question is not should gay guys take
this drug
it seems like if you're going to engage
in these activities this is probably
going to help prevent you from
Contracting this virus that spreads
almost uniquely among among people who
have sex with among men who have sex
with other men
the question is should employers be
required to pay for this drug
should let's say I don't know Catholic
School
should a Catholic School be required to
pay for a drug
the purpose of which is to make it
easier for men to have sex with lots of
other men Because by the way don't
forget we're not even just talking about
men who have sex with one other man that
they know where neither of them have HIV
and then they go get frisky they do
their thing they go do whatever they're
going to do they're not there they are
at a zero percent risk of Contracting
HIV
unless they're also reusing heroin
needles on the side they are at a
exactly zero percent risk of of catching
HIV
the risk is only when you are having sex
with other men whose HIV status you
don't know maybe you're having sex with
strange men maybe you're having sex with
lots of other men maybe you're mixing in
some intravenous drug use on the side
and you're not washing your needles
whatever it is
you're talking about very very risky
behaviors is it right to force an
employer who maybe objects to that sort
of thing on moral grounds like every
major religion ever
to to pay for that and no obviously
that's a violation of people's religious
conscience obviously this is the right
decision and it was amazing when I when
I made this point yesterday
I mean I made a similar point on monkey
box which is that monkeypox spreads
among gay guys who have sex with lots of
other gay guys that's that's pretty much
the only group that it spreads among
we're talking about 95 plus of the
transmission of monkey pox is among
promiscuous homosexual men
and you're not allowed to say that
they say that if you say that it's
homophobic
but then they also say that if you don't
want to subsidize all the drugs for
monkey pox for example that you're also
being homophobic but hold on I was just
told the monkey pox is not specifically
a gay thing well no Michael it's not
specifically a gay thing okay then we're
not going to subsidize the drugs well if
you don't subsidize the drugs that's
homophobic well it's only homophobic if
it's a gay thing you can't have it both
ways but they want to have it both ways
they what they really want what the libs
really want is just for you to shut up
that's what it's about
shut up take it don't object to anything
because we now have
we now have a new kind of animating
principle for the country and they view
the religious freedom restoration act as
absurd and illegitimate and wrong and
they view Christianity as absurd and
illegitimate and wrong and they wear
actual satanic symbols in leather
harnesses from the highest echelons of
government from the White House okay the
people who wear the satanic leather
symbols are the people running the show
and to pretend that that has nothing to
do with Christianity to pretend that
that has nothing to do with religious
rights
is absurd
and it was a lot easier for the libs to
make that argument and just to pretend
that there was a kind of secular neutral
ground where no come on just get your
religion out of here it was a lot easier
to do that
before they became so overt before
senior government officials were
Leading Men around by collars men
dressed up as little dogs that they were
going to abuse and sort of sadistic
sexual rituals and wearing pentagrams
and giving fiery speeches calling half
the country evil in front of in front of
what looks like the Gates of Hell in
front of very dark backdrops with deep
red lights where you talk about the
Battle for the soul of the nation all
right we're gonna have a battle for the
soul of the nation let's do it man let's
talk about the soul
let's talk about morality we have to do
it that's what they want it's amazing
sometimes you'll hear this from the libs
all the time they will say why are you
Republicans
so obsessed with other people's sex
lives their private sex lives
they say okay how did this really play
out
because the way I saw it I was just kind
of going about living my life you know
having a nice life and everything and
then the lips come in and they say hey
hey we're going to put gay porn in your
kids schools which they actually have
done it's a book called genderqueer and
it's gay pornography we're gonna put in
your kids schools for very very young
kids often by the way we're going to
um we're going to put your really little
kids like five-year-olds to
eight-year-olds uh in a transgender
indoctrination classroom and and maybe
even put them on puberty blockers and
not even tell you about it in some cases
we're gonna have drag shows at the
public libraries uh we're going to
radically redefine marriage uh we're
going to do X Y and Z does that sound
good
and then the conservatives and the kind
of normal people they'll say
um
no could we Maybe not maybe not do that
and then the lips say why are you so
obsessed with sex why are you so upset
well I'm not you're just you're forcing
all of this on me all the time and on my
kids and in public and the pride parades
with probably the monkey pox secretary
dancing in the weird leather on the in
the middle of the street and I just
think maybe maybe we chill with that a
little bit
why are you so obsessed uh we're not
we're not
we're not but that's what the that's
what the battle is coming down to the
Indiana Supreme Court for instance right
before I get to the member block we got
a great interview today on Show Business
and uh all sorts of all sorts of
spiritual and cultural matters uh the
Indiana Supreme Court just upheld the
firing
of a teacher at a Catholic school over
uh his participation in same-sex
marriage obviously Catholic church does
not uh recognize any such
ontological category is same-sex
marriage and has a you know pretty
traditional view of sexual ethics and so
the school says okay look nothing
against you pal you know I'm sure you're
a nice enough guy uh but look at our
school
uh we have a view of things we have a
Christian ethos and worldview and so we
need our teachers you know we're
teaching our kids to be raised in that
that's the point of this education and
so you got to get along with that if you
don't want to get along with that that's
fine go teach at another school there's
plenty of teaching jobs but you can't
teach here and the libs forced the issue
well fortunately for now the Indiana
Supreme Court upheld the right of the
Catholic School to be Catholic
but for how much longer I don't know
because the libs don't want to just Live
and Let Live and Let the Catholic
schools do the Catholic School thing and
let the Satanist schools do the Satanist
school thing that's not what they want
and that's probably not possible anyway
they want a standard and they want it to
be their standard they want it to be
their side in the battle for the soul of
of the nation
and their side is not the good side they
are the baddies the rest of the show is
continuing now if you don't want to miss
it which obviously you don't and you've
got to become a member okay the main
show is for the hoi polloi all you I
love you you Hoyt beloi but when you
want to get the extra special exclusive
stuff
where we can speak a little more freely
okay you got to come on over to the
member block we will have Meg bashram
here to discuss
Olivia Wilde's claim this uh Olivia
Wilde director of some new stupid movie
don't worry darling uh her her claim
that Jordan Peterson is an evil villain
Jordan Peterson Mike friend and
colleague is the villain in this movie
uh we will discuss how that is possible
how a polite soft-spoken Canadian
professor in a three-piece suit could
become
the most developed man in the world so
go join us over there we'll see you at
the member block
[Music]
[Music]